[Musique]
enfin
vous avez dit d'oublier d'entrer dans
une pièce et vous demander ce que vous
venez chercher si ça vous arrive vous
êtes peut-être victime de l'effet de
porte le taux wifi
à l'université notre dame aux états unis
le professeur gabriel radwanski s'est
penché sur cette question
il s'intéresse entre autres à la façon
dont la mémoire est affecté par nos
mouvements dans l'espace avec l'un de
ses étudiants
il a mené une série d'expériences durant
lesquelles des participantes devaient
manipuler des objets d'une pièce à
l'autre intervalles réguliers ont
demandé aux participants de nommer de
mémoire les objets qu'ils avaient
transporté et ce qu'ils ont marqué c'est
que le simple fait de franchir une porte
pouvait affecter la mémoire mais
pourquoi les hypothèses c'est qu'en
rentrant dans une pièce le cerveau a
besoin de faire une sorte de mise à jour
et de saisir la nouvelle information à
propos de son environnement
pour enregistrer cette nouvelle
information dans la mémoire à court
terme
on doit faire de la place alors une
partie de l'information contre étaient
émises en archi et ça bousille un peu
notre mémoire
tout à coup on a l'impression qu'il faut
faire un effort pour extirper de
l'information qui date de quelques
minutes à peine
autre élément le cerveau a aussi
tendance à interpréter le changement de
lieu comme le début d'une nouvelle
séquence d'événements sanguin avec celui
qui le précédait et laporte marquerait
de manière plus prononcée la frontière
entre les événements dès qu'on l'a
franchie on oublie ce qu'on avait en
tête juste auparavant
d'ailleurs on est souvent obligé de
revenir sur nos pas physiquement ou
mentalement pour reprendre le fil de
l'action qu'on la vente a mis quelques
minutes plus tôt
question de se rafraîchir la mémoire
[Musique]
et le plus curieux c'est que les fêtes
porte se produit aussi bien dans un
décor réel que virtuelle
bien sûr cela n'affecte pas tout le
monde tout le temps
mais ce qui doit nous intéresser c'est
que cela affecte aussi bien les view que
les jeunes alors j'espère que vous vous
en rappellerez au moins jusqu'au bas de
la prochaine porte à autre chose a
tourné ici